enseignement électricité transports
grève des perturbations demain europe
avertissements de valéry giscard
d'estaing à londres le chef de la
diplomatie anglaise dans notre journal
jeux olympiques très compromis helmut
schmidt pour le boycott à la monsieur
bonsoir monsieur raymond barre le
premier ministre n'a pas l'habitude de
mâcher ses mots ses adversaires comme
ses amis politiques d'ailleurs sont du
même avis et cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale il l'a confirmé ce
jugement en déclarant notamment que les
manifestations qui désorganise la vie du
pays ne servent pas démocratie et que
les français ça faire la distinction
entre la démagogie et la raison au
service de la france
monsieur bart répondait à une question
de monsieur ballanger le président du
groupe communiste à l'assemblée
nationale qui protestait contre le fait
notamment que beaucoup de propositions
loi communiste n'était même pas discuté
par le parlement
monsieur bah réagissaient également bien
sûr à la veille des différents
mouvements sociaux qui vont marquer
cette semaine et la semaine prochaine à
commencer demain par la grève dans tous
les secteurs de l'éducation décidée par
les principaux syndicats d'enseignants
qui protestent contre la politique du
gouvernement qui selon eux profitant de
la baisse de la démographie en france à
l'intention de fermer des classes
notamment alors que ce serait justement
le moment d'améliorer encore la qualité
du système d'éducation français la
réponse de monsieur raymond barre sur ce
point cet après midi au parle à l'heure
actuelle je les dis et je le répète nous
assistons à des mouvements qui ne sont
en aucun cas justifier je dois dire que
je déplore les conditions dans
lesquelles les jeunes auront dans les
jours à venir à faire face à des
mouvements de grève qui sont espérés par
de toute autre considération que par la
défense du système éducatif français
saihi tout le problème est là les
syndicats d'enseignants réclament une
augmentation du budget de l'éducation et
le gouvernement la refuse ce mouvement
d'une ampleur que l'on n'avait pas
connue depuis longtemps se traduit donc
demain d'abord par un appel à la grève
des enseignants lancée par les
principaux syndicats
samedi les parents d'élèves de la
fédération cornec non verront pas leurs
enfants à l'école la fédération lagarde
il faut le lire condamne cette action
enfin mardi prochain le personnel non
enseignant des établissements scolaires
est lui aussi appelé à la grève dans les
jours qui viennent nous allons la parole
à tous les parties intéressées par ce
problème mais ce soir c'est un
témoignage que notre spécialiste de
munich laurie propose ou plutôt la
réflexion d'une institutrice d'école
maternelle qui résume assez bien l'état
d'esprit d'un certain nombre dans celle
ci n'est pas un hasard si l'école des
petits s'appelle l'école maternelle pour
enseigner ici il est indispensable d
mais les enfants je m'appelle
catherineau mais j'ai 27 ans je suis
institutrice depuis huit ans ne couche
pas te rappelles quand on vous regarde
travail on a vraiment le sentiment
qu'une institution école maternelle
c'est pas tout à fait un enseignant
comme but c'est avant tout un enseignant
mais c'est plus qu'un enseignant par
exemple c'est aussi
une amie une confidence les enfants ne
lui racontent leur vie c'est un peu
une infirmière quand il ya des petits
bobos des petits malheurs c'est une
psychologue parce que à cet âge là les
enfants pour les comprendre les aider
donc je pense qu'effectivement c'est
lui-même dans le corps enseignant
quelque chose d'un peu particulier de
par les multiples facettes qui nécessite
quand même un caractère et l'état
d'esprit un peu particulier combien
d'années je gagne actuellement moins de
4000 francs par mois
je suis depuis huit ans dans
l'enseignement je dirais que c'est
presque dérisoire la fonction du travail
que ça représente de la fatigue nerveuse
et puis parce qu'on donne beaucoup de
soi même on donne énormément reçoit en
retour on reçoit beaucoup d enfants
beaucoup moins des adultes mais on donne
énormément je crois qu'on ne peut pas
être instituteur si l'on n'aime pas
vraiment les enfants et si l'on n'aime
pas vraiment ce que l'on fait quels sont
vos conditions de provale comment se
passe une chose est par exemple les
conditions de travail sont difficiles
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord en compte
de l'exiguïté des locaux la plupart des
d'écoles ne possède ni salle à manger
initiale de dortoir ici on passe son
temps à déménager pour transformer la
salle pour la gymnastique pour la danse
pour la musique pour dormir
et puis la deuxième difficulté c'est le
nombre
j'ai trente enfants et sur 30 il y en a
12 qui n'ont pas encore trois ans donc
ça des petites beaucoup d'attention de
se démultiplier d'être réceptif pour
tous les enfants et avec 30 c'est
absolument impossible il ya des choses
qu'on aimerait faire et on ne peut pas
faire 2 me ce que vous donne oui je fais
grève demain je ferai grève demain tout
en étant très gêné de faire grève parce
que finalement cette grève elle va
ennuyer
elle va pénaliser les enfants et elle va
ennuyer les parents donc on est toujours
très embêté que sa greffe mais je ferai
grève parce que c'est vraiment le cri
d'alarmé
actuellement c'est la qualité de
l'enseignement public et angers demain
donc non seulement l'enseignement mais
aussi tout le secteur public
principalement risquent d'être perturbés
par des arrêts de travail décidé
principalement par la cgt le point avec
bruce lee à 2900 francs
la garantie du droit au travail et la
semaine de 35 heures la cgt appelle à la
grève demain et manifestera en province
et à paris à 10h de l'opéra à la
bastille à la sncf selon la direction le
trafic grandes lignes ne devrait pas en
principe être perturbé sauf la
transversale sud nice marseille toulouse
par contre en banlieue parisienne on
prévoit 2 trains sur 3 sauf en gare de
lyon où le trafic doit être normal et ds
gdf coupure de dix heures du matin à
midi dans le nord la région parisienne
et la normandie grèves tournantes les
jours suivants
transports urbains très perturbée aux
ptt et dans toute la fonction publique
perturbations aussi enfin dans le
secteur privé
débrayage d'une heure à 24 heures dans
la chimie le textile la presse et
caetera à cette grève cgt coïncide les
arrêts de travail lancé par la scène
contre la fermeture des classes
une grève qui elle doit se prolonger le
rapport de monsieur giraud des pdg d'air
france sur le temps de travail qui vient
d'être remis au gouvernement n'est pas
encore officiellement connue mais déjà
philippe sassier en connaît les grandes
lignes et on peut dire que les
propositions qu'il contient vont
permettre une reprise des négociations
entre le patronat et des singles d'après
ce que l'on peut savoir la durée
annuelle du travail passerait de 240
jours à 227 jours cette diminution de 13
jours soit au prix de la manière
suivante
tout d'abord les huit jours fériés
annuel serait transformé tout bonnement
en congés payés jusqu'à présent on peut
le cas échéant rattraper ces jours
fériés en travaillant le samedi par
exemple deuxièmement 40 heures de congé
supplémentaire serait proposé aux
salariés ses heures pourrait être
transformée en semaine de congés
supplémentaires en travail en temps de
travail un petit peu plus court chaque
semaine ou bien encore un petit pont un
petit peu plus long lorsqu'il ya des
jours fériés ou des petites vacances là
ce sera semble-t-il aux salariés et au
patronat dans dispute enfin le rapport
giraudet propose également de diminuer
progressivement le nombre d heures
supplémentaires qui sont admis chaque
année le diminuer de 384 actuellement
environ 180 en contrepartie les
entreprises pourront aménager avec plus
de souplesse le temps de travail de
leurs ateliers de leurs employés de
leurs machines selon ce sont là a
semble-t-il des propositions qui sont
susceptibles de remettre sur les rails
tsedu discussions sur la diminution du
temps de travail est gelé depuis le mois
de janvier
après leur premier rendez vous manqué
les élus bretons ont été reçus cet après
midi par le président de la république
monsieur giscard d'estaing avec qui il
voulait s'entretenir des problèmes posés
par la pollution répétés de leurs côtes
régulièrement sinistrées par les
naufrages des pétroliers bernard fath 25
breton à l'elysée parmi eux monsieur
marcellin président du conseil régional
de bretagne
mais ces choses-là président du conseil
général des côtes du nord des élus et
des maires de communes touchées par la
marée noire
si le chef de l'état a rassuré les
bretons à propos de l'epap d'agneau et
des indemnisations
on ne peut pas dire que ces propositions
pour améliorer la prévention des marées
noires est et est également comprise par
secteur le monde était là à la sortie de
l'elysée
les déclarations optimistes des 1 était
vigoureusement contredite par les
réserves sceptiques des autres pour
empêcher de nouvelles catastrophes
l'elysée propose la mise en service du
radar d'ouessant 790 millions de francs
d'investissements pour onze navires
patrouilleurs trois avions et mille
hommes supplémentaires pour la
surveillance des côtes
le président de la république souhaite
conclure un accord international de
prévention
mais avant que le gouvernement obtienne
cet accord ne serait ce que sur le plan
européen
certains élus bretons craignent que leur
cote soit à nouveau animée par un autre
naufrage du pétrolier
le ministre des affaires étrangères
soviétique monsieur andry gromyko est à
paris depuis aujourd'hui une visite dont
l'importance est évidente même si
personne n'attend de décision
spectaculaire à l'issue des discussions
qu'il devait avoir avec monsieur jean
françois poncet le ministre français des
affaires étrangères avec un sujet
principal l'afghanistan bien sûr et les
conséquences sur les rapports entre
l'est et l'ouest et les jeux olympiques
morizet les premiers entretiens il
continue ce soir au cours d'un dîner de
travail ont porté bien entendu sur
l'afghanistan
ils ont tout lieu nous dit-on dans une
atmosphère de franchise et de gravité
il est évident qu'on ne se fait pas
d'illusion monsieur gromyko n'est pas
venu à paris pour faire amende honorable
pour annoncer le retrait des troupes
soviétiques d'afghanistan mais plutôt
pour essayer sans beaucoup d'illusions
non plus de dissocier la france de ses
alliés occidentaux
monsieur françois poncet a certainement
renouveler les mises en garde redit au
ministre soviétique que l'urss mais la
détente en danger que si rien ne change
les élisent occidentaux qui ont avec
l'urss des relations économiques et
technologiques d'une certaine importance
la france et l'allemagne de l'ouest en
particulier les alliés occidentaux se
verront dans l'obligation de mettre fin
à ces relations ce qui ne va pas ce qui
ne sera pas sans effet pour l'urss non
plus ce n'est probablement pas cela qui
va faire basculer la décision soviétique
mais c'est un élément de réflexion
si monsieur carter en pleine campagne
électorale juge qu'il faut punir l'urss
du côté français on pense qu'il vaut
mieux parler et mettre un élément de
réflexion à la disposition de l'union
soviétique avec l'espoir bien ténue
aujourd'hui faut le reconnaître qu'un
jour plus ou moins lointain la raison
l'emportera oui les jeux olympiques ont
toutes les chances de ne pas avoir lieu
ce n'est même plus une information mais
une comtesse d'une constatation pardon
même si on attend les résultats
la réunion du comité olympique
international qui se tient ce soir à
lausanne en effet d'ores et déjà après
les états unis l'angleterre et d'autres
pays moins important le gouvernement de
bonn et le parlement cet après midi se
sont déclarés sans équivoque pour le
boycottage des jeux de bonnes michel
mail très officiellement et très
fermement donc helmut schmidt a
conseillé la non participation allemande
aux jeux olympiques de moscou conseiller
car on dessine it
il la décision appartient de droit au
comité olympique allemand et cela le 15
mai prochain
déjà une épreuve de force se dessine
néanmoins entre helmut schmidt et ce
comité dans la mesure où au sein de ce
comité est bien la majorité en faveur du
boycott n'est pas du tout évidente
cela dit malgré cette fronde prévisible
des sportifs
il est tout à fait exclu que ce groupe
de pression réussissent à mettre m ou de
suite en force après porte à faux par
rapport aux états unis on peut donc
considérer qu'en allemagne
les jeux sont faits il n'y aura
vraisemblablement pas d'athlètes
allemand aux jeux olympiques de moscou
oui je vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
réunion du comité olympique
international en ce moment même à
lausanne elle vient de se terminer nous
avons en ligne au téléphone jean marc
est notre envoyé spécial à l'argent
quels ont été les décisions prises par
ce comité olympique international jean
marc et jean dont quelques problèmes
avec lausanne
est ce que jean marc et longtemps est ce
que jean marc et nous prenons nos
discussions pour un communiqué devant
quillan il est vrai que des possibilités
de manoeuvre était limité le soyons ne
tenant pas à tromper les gens auront
bien lieu en juillet prochain à moscou
iront ceux qui voudront bien y aller
pour déplier avec ou sans drapeau ne pas
défiler du tout pour les autres pas de
sanctions envisagées pour laisser l'eau
qui voudraient participer dans l'écran
de leur prix des mains de financiers est
envisagée usagers bailleur individuel ce
qui lamine la confirmer alors que les
soviétiques étaient plutôt favorables
le temps étant trop courts pour modifier
les règles aux olympiques
après la décision du gouvernement
allemand pas de commenter un match qu'il
anime à a dit qu'il attendait la
notification du séno allemande
d'ailleurs il est imperturbable nativa
les dégâts que vous pensez à thé de
tirer des conclusions
et revoilà date limite d'inscription 24
mai pour faire le point par les mails
donne de l'assurance aux organisateurs
de los angeles 1984
toutefois il s'est déclaré prêt encore
rencontré monsieur caractères hébreux
mais on ne voit pas bien l'intérêt de
ces rencontres dans l'immédiat car pour
moscou maintenant il semble bien que ça
compte mais que les jeux soient faits
ils se feront
mais la participation bien voilà pour
cette première réaction à chaud nous ont
bien sûr de plus amples détails de notre
envoyé spécial jean marc et dans notre
dernier journal
en fin de programme il faut que les
négociations agricoles qui se déroule en
ce moment même à bruxelles débouche sur
une solution au problème déprise
agricole de façon à ce que le sommet des
chefs d'état européens de luxembourg
dimanche prochain n'est plus qu'à parler
du problème de la contribution
britannique au budget de la communauté
européenne
c'est un avertissement a été lancé ce
matin solennellement au conseil des
ministres par le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing
cela dit on voit mal comment cette
solution peut être trouvée et
l'interview qu'a accordée le ministre
des affaires étrangères anglais lord
carrington attend notre correspondant
géant ce bail confirme cette impression
que la solution ne sera pas facile à
trouver que vous dites que les avants
une position dure
quelle serait la réaction de même si la
france était le septième membre de la
communauté part de richesse c'est à dire
presque le plus pauvre de tous
et s'il contribue et des millions des
millions de francs qu'ils ont un des
pays qui sont plus riches que la france
particulièrement dans des cas comme
celui ci du cas comme celui de la grande
bretagne où nous essayons de remettre de
l'ordre dans notre économie après des
années de marasme et nous demandons à la
population de sacrifier bien les choses
qu'elle voudrait avoir des hôpitaux et
bien d'autres chanteurs et lorsque nous
voyons une contribution nette de
bretagne de 10 milliards de francs par
exemple tous les ans un des pays qui
sont plus riches que nous si cet homme
politique vous vous rendez compte qu'il
est difficile d'expliquer un tellement
de choses nous n'avons pas de position
du renom pour employer le terme
ce que nous avons c'est une position que
nous demandons c'est lié de comprendre
seulement dans nos amis à nos
partenaires juste de comprendre ces
temps de comprendre que leur semble dans
une situation inacceptable à nos yeux
dans les négociations vous avez une
position dure vous attendez des
concessions mais vous apparemment vous
n'en faites pas beaucoup je suis
convaincu que ne le comprendront de tous
les côtés dans le monde des dangers
plein si vous regardez la scène de
l'afghanistan de l'iran il vous regardez
le problème des relations est ouest
si vous voyez que l'europe est souvent
divisée à ce point de vue là 20 nous en
tant qu'européens nous faisons ce que
nous pouvons et je crois que nous ferons
de notre mieux pour parvenir à une
solution logique raisonnable pour nous
tous georges bortoli je n'ai pas entendu
de propos très nouveau dans la bouche de
l'ordre carrington alors pourquoi ce
coup de poing sur la table du président
de la république à propos de la
contribution et que des anglais la
communauté européenne
vous voulez on peut dire d'une formule
que les français pensent d'abord à leurs
agriculteurs et que les anglais nous
entendre de la bouche de leurs
carrington pense d'abord à leur argent
ok ce qui se passe actuellement à
bruxelles une réunion des ministres de
l'agriculture européens qui discutent du
problème des prix agricoles
les français voudraient que les prêts
agricoles soient relevés
substantiellement les anglais préféré
que ces prêts à l'épaule soit relevé peu
ou même dans certains cas pas du tout
bon ça traîne ça traîne ça traîne tout
ça et je problème des prix agricoles peu
traîné très longtemps puisque l'année
dernière il avait étrenné jusqu'en juin
alors le coup droit sur la table qu'on
veut dit de valéry giscard d'estaing
c'est pour accélérer processus et ça dit
très clairement que si on ne rêve le
patient ne parvient pas un schéma
d'accord chez les prises agricole mais
maintenant tout de suite dans la séance
de nuit qui peut venir maintenant oui et
bien à ce moment là au sommet qui va se
tenir à luxembourg ou sommet des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement européens
eh bien on ne pourra pas abordé le
problème c'est à dire qu'on ne pourra
pas aborder ce fameux problème non par
les lords carrington tout de suite de la
contribution financière des anglais aux
finances européennes malgré ce qu'on
dira madame thatcher qu'elle peut
rentrer chez elle écoutez bon on
pourrait à la rigueur arriver à un
accord cette nuit c'est pas très très
probable et si on n'y arrive pas il ya
effectivement n'en dira pas même sa
chair qu'elle peut rentrer chez elle ce
ne sont pas des choses qui se font je
pense mais
ça risque effectivement d'être un sommet
pour rien et madame seule chair peut
repartir sans avoir obtenu satisfaction
le sa fameuse injonction vous savez
rendez moi mon argent merci dans
l'interview qu'il a accordée antenne de
l'ordre carrington a évoqué aussi les
représailles économiques décidées par
l'europe à l'encontre de l'iran et à
propos des conséquences que pourraient
avoir ces mesures de rétorsion
économique sur nos approvisionnements en
pétrole
il a pour la première fois nettement
déclaré que dans ce cas là l'angleterre
aiderait ses partenaires européens s'il
y avait un arrêt complet du pétrole
iranien les britanniques aiderait-il les
autres européens
la réponse est oui nous ferons de notre
mieux mais vous ne devez pas surestimer
le potentiel de la mer du nord et son
aptitude à répondre aux difficiles de
pétrole chez nos amis européens
nous ne sommes pas encore autosuffisante
point que j'étais troll donc la portée
de notre aide est assez restreinte
néanmoins si cette pénurie de pétrole
dépasse un certain chiffre certainement
un accord est intervenu entre nous à
savoir que des mesures seront prises et
que nous l'ajouterons le pétrole aux
autres ceintures donc oui nous vous
aiderons de la détention des otages
américains de téhéran est inacceptable
et doit cesser
cette fois c'est le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing
qui s'exprime il a fait cette
déclaration au conseil des ministres de
ce matin alors que précisément il a reçu
cet après midi plusieurs familles
d'otages de l'ambassade américaine de
terre ces familles entame par paris une
tournée en europe elles se sont groupés
en une véritable association qui réclame
la solidarité washington jaksic leurs
maris ou leurs fils sont prisonniers à
l'ambassade de téhéran depuis six mois
elles sont constituées naturellement une
association flag qui veut dire le
drapeau et dont la responsable est
madame louise à kennedy
la femme de l'un des conseillers
économiques et depuis six mois elle
suivre minute par minute les événements
iraniens
elles se sont totalement désolidarisé de
barbara team qui est allé seul war son
fils à téhéran et qui ne ménage pas ses
critiques au président carter
à londres à paris à rome à luxembourg
elle souhaite selon leur expression être
reçues au plus haut niveau et elle
affirme que leurs voyages mais pas
aspirer voire encouragée par le
gouvernement américain
on entend parler des otages de leurs
familles c'est quelque chose de
tellement loin que ça c'est comme un
roman et nous voulons ou autre et on
voyait un fermoir que nous existons et
que nous sommes des êtres humains qui
souffrent on est et naturellement nous
voulons absolument leur coopération
parce que rester ici et attendre nous
avons attendu attendu attendu
on a eu des hauts et des bas où on est
attendu on a eu beaucoup d'espoir et
puis vous savez on respecte et ça veut
dire qu en vous déplaçant au contraire
vous espérer obtenir un résultat
espérons obtenir un résultat puisqu'on
on a tout essayé
et le résultat c'est lequel le résultat
c'est que les français saluent tanus
l'enlisement dans l'affairé iranienne
n'est sûrement pas étrangère à la courte
défaite du président carter devant le
sénateur kennedy dans les élections
primaires de pennsylvanie algérie
confirmation que de violents
affrontements ont bien eu lieu en
kabylie à tizi ouzou exactement on parle
de barricades de plusieurs dizaines de
blessés peut-être même de mort
les kabyles réclamant vous le savez le
respect par le pouvoir central de leurs
particularismes la tunisie change de
premier ministre monsieur nouira malade
et remplacé par monsieur ali c'est
l'ambassadeur de tunisie en france
monsieur mabrouk qui va annoncer
aujourd'hui en exclusivité au cours
d'antenne 2 me tchad les combats ont
repris avec acharnement aujourd'hui on
est bien loin des tentatives de ccf en
france le flnc le front de libération
national corse revendiquent les sept
attentats commis la nuit dernière à
paris et à nice et explosions qui ont
provoqué des dégâts matériels seulement
heureusement dans différents locaux
commerciaux ou publics et sont
intervenues le jour même où les élus
corses ont été reçus par président d'un
publi le flnc contestant la
représentativité de ces deux affaires de
bruyn la chambre d'accusation ne dira
que vendredi après demain si oui ou non
elle rouvre le dossier la commission
parlementaire elle qui doit dire si elle
si monsieur poniatowski doit comparaître
devant l'autre cour de justice réunira l
mercredi prochain mais d'ores et déjà
monsieur poniatowski a déposé
officiellement plainte en diffamation
contre les députés socialistes et
communistes notamment qui ont demandé sa
comparution devant la haute cour de
justice dans notre société moderne il
est des choses qui reste tabou
la mort fait partie de celles là la
suède qui est bien connu pour être en
avance dans le domaine des moeurs publié
un rapport sur la mort à la suite d'une
longue enquête dans la population une
des principales conclusions c'est que
les hommes aspirent à une mort naturelle
sans acharnement thérapeutique et du
reste des cliniques vont être créés à
cet effet mais l'euthanasie elle reste
interdite elle est toujours passible de
prison
une enquête de martine laroche ou dans
deux heures le temps d'un trajet en
train cette femme sera en prison pour
certains elle est coupable d'un meurtre
pour d'autres elle a accompli la charité
le 6 juin 77 des richesses be a fine
fissures mortel à un malade qui souffre
et trouve paralysé ne pouvait accomplir
ce geste elle lui a rendu ce dernier
service vérité deviner ni médecin ni
infirmière journalistes elle préside
l'association pour le droit à la mort
elle est en route pour la prison un an
de prison
non cet iphone
j'étais toujours que je ne peux rien
regretter j'ai accompli un acte que
j'estime être juste non je n'ai pas de
regret que chacun le droit de choisir
cap aller où c'est une question
importante elle concerne beaucoup de
gens pas seulement su l on me dit mais
les moins nantis
la veille vérité bis avait réuni des
membres de son association cd continuer
son combat
ils sont 8000 ou 9000 en suède dit elle
a lutté pour la légalisation de
l'euthanasie
nombre d'entre eux sont venus à
l'association après avoir vu un parent
un ami mourir dans la souffrance
ils demandent le droit de se laisser
mourir le droit de laisser mourir mais
aussi celui de provoquer cette mort
quand elle est demandée crié par le
malade
berit à écouter ce cri et elle a donné
le coup de grâce
vous n'avez pas peur de mourir il avait
peur d'aller dans un service de longue
maladie pour 10 ou 15 ans d'être traité
comme un paquet que l'on en bas le soir
et que l'on déballe le matin il m'a
demandé de lui prêter ma main pour
l'aider à se suicider je suis sein des
pays de galles en suède mais un homme
entièrement paralysé ne peut pas le
faire la loi doit être changée et
prendre en considération tous ceux qui
ne peuvent rester bien même plus ici
dans cet hôpital nous ne songe à
raccourcir l'agonie on meurt de moins en
mois dans son unique on meurt dans un
lit d'emprunt celui de l'hôpital en
suède en ce moment on est en quête de
solutions pour que les derniers
mouvements ne soient pas des moments
d'abandon
ici les infirmières après non seulement
à soigner les accompagner le malade
jusqu'au bout du chemin
what is qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important à votre à limiter à donner à
long terme à la fête de l'amour là nous
les aimons tous beaucoup de l'amour mais
de la tension aussi chacun peut apporter
ses objets personnels
chacun est livré à ses activités
favorites
on ne veut pas considérer le patient
comme retomber en enfance
mais le laisser libre de remplir ces
instants là comme il l'entend est ce que
vous n'avez pas eu que quelques fois la
tentation d'interrompre définitivement
certaine france oh non non nous les
aimons seulement si nous essayons
d'offrir aux malades une vie familiale
ou leur donnant des médicaments pour
apaiser leurs souffrances nous en
prenons soin autant que possible
nous leur donnons la possibilité d'avoir
diverses activités pendant la journée
pour adoucir les derniers instants le
gouvernement suédois envisage de lutter
contre ce que certains ont appelé
l'acharnement médicale le malade pour
avoir le droit de décider si oui ou non
il désira traitement qui pourrait
prolonger sa vie mais l'empêché de
mourir paisiblement le service que nous
allons créer ne sera pas mini
d'appareillage compliqué que
l'appareillage de survie nous essaierons
d'en faire une sorte de maison où les
enfants la famille les amis pourront
venir sans contrainte ou d'un face aux
maladies incurables face à la mort les
réponses ne devrait être qu individuelle
mais l'état y ont pris à sa charge la
santé
il s'est trouvé nantis malgré lui d'une
partie de la charge de la mort
la suède le pays d'europe où le poids du
souci à l'est le plus important a donc
été l'un des premiers à tenter de
trouver une solution dans l'esprit ces
solutions sont simples redonner aux
malades sa liberté de choix
tous les choix
celui de se laisser mourir mais pas
celui de donner la mort pour un geste
secourable et fatale d'hériter de be ce
jour là entre est en prison oui bien sûr
à propos de l'acharnement thérapeutique
on peut s'interroger sur les raisons
pour lesquelles on maintient
complètement artificiellement en vie le
maréchal tito depuis maintenant plus de
trois mois et deux derniers bulletins
que l'on a communiqué aujourd'hui à
belgrade indique que le maréchal tito
est complètement plongé dans le coma et
qu'il se trouve en état de choc à tel
point que le la présidence collégiale de
la yougoslavie s'est réuni aujourd'hui à
belgrade catastrophe écologique en
italie sur 25 km les rives du pô sont
souillés par 3000 tonnes de pétrole
déversées avant-hier dans le fleuve par
le lire et du conoco près de milan cette
nappe de pétrole qui a formé un
véritable fleuve noir descend à 3
kilomètres à l'heure vers la mer
adriatique des barrages en plastique
sont installés actuellement le long des
digues pour tenter de stocker le mazout
avant de le pomper et puis 96 morts dans
une collision entre un paquebot est un
pétrolier hier en pleine nuit au large
des philippines dont jean qui
transportait 983 personnes a lancé le
signal de détresse vers 23 heures
quelques minutes seulement après de la
collision ce qui explique que rapidement
quatre autres navires se soit porté sur
les lieux aux états unis encore une
information économique l'industrie
automobile connaît de nouveaux déboires
avec la sortie des modèles 80 chrysler
le troisième constructeur américain
annonce annonce le licenciement de 7000
personnes licenciement qui
interviendront dans les semaines qui
vont venir en france
le mobile c'est la marque talbot qui
annonce de son côté qu'elle abandonne
les négociations engagées avec bmw en
conséquence l'étude d'un nouveau moteur
turbo de formule 1 ne sera pas
poursuivie avec ses suscite cette
société pardon mais entrepris avec une
autre les résultats du tiercé
tout d'abord pour conclure ne prend les
résultats les pronostics les résultats
ce sera pour le loto ensuite les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé le 11 le 7 le 18 le 19 le 8 13 9
et le vin voilà et je ne confonds pas là
ce sont pas les pronostics du loto mais
bien les résultats je vous laisse encore
regarder les résultats des pronostics du
tiercé ne vais pas y arriver décidément
le loto donc résultat cette fois ci pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 3 le 10 le 12
le 14 le 31 42 et numéro complémentaire
est le 43
je vais essayer maintenant sans
bafouiller de vous donner la météo
demain sur la moitié est du pays le
temps instable persistera quelques
averses seront encore observées en
particulier sur les massifs montagneux
où elles tomberont sous forme de neige
au-dessus de 800 m sur le reste de la
france le temps sera très nuageux et
brumeux le matin avec des bruines locale
mais quelques éclaircies se développent
pour l'après midi elles seront plus
belles près de l'atlantique et de la
méditerranée où le mistral et la
tramontane persisteront voilà demain
antennes de midi avec gérard depardieu
l'acteur bien connu qui s'intéressent
paraît-il aux problèmes d'éducation
alors il sera servi puisque l'invité du
crible sera monsieur guy georges qui le
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des instituteurs et puis à 20 heures
dominique fleury toujours à propos des
problèmes d'enseignement recevra
monsieur christian bilhac le ministre de
l'éducation
ce soir dernier journal avec paul amar
vers 23h30 après l'émission spéciale but
par but qui nous retracera bien sûr le
match que vous attendez tous nantes
valence en coupe d'europe de l'uefa des
vainqueurs de coupes plus exactement
avec bien sûr l'espoir que les français
vont gagner
je touche du bois et je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée bonsoir